all right monique
yeah monique where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
um kind of a park
san fernando valley yeah in l.a and uh
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
did you have both your parents growing
up
um uh
no just um just my mom
so yeah where was dad um
um in canada park so yeah did you ever
see him
huh did you ever see your dad uh oh no
she's
my mom's by herself so
so your dad was kind of out of the
picture it sounds like
huh your dad was out of the picture um
no no my mom was um by herself she's
um she's a divorced i guess so yeah how
would you describe your childhood
okay any abuse
anything crazy like that i don't know
just just
just a big family let's say
so yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
what kind of kid was i in high school
sorry shy
you're still shy huh you're still shy um
and what did you do after you got out of
school
um i went to beauty school for a little
bit
and then um
dropped out because of uh certain
situations fortunate you go back
into then that's pretty much it
and how old do you know 25 yeah 25.
yeah and how long you been down here on
skid row
huh how long have you been living in
skid row um
maybe like a couple months
yeah a couple months how'd you end up
down here
um i think i like i said um i think i
was meeting a friend
and yeah and then just like stay down
here
uh yeah and you're pregnant now
huh you're pregnant now um
[Music]
no no you're not pregnant oh you're like
bloated or something
yeah yeah
so you don't think you're pregnant no no
nothing just floating
so yeah
um how do you support yourself now
um
my friend helps helps me out a little
bit i'm sorry i'm just a little out of
it
um my friend helps me out a little bit
over there in the tent and that's it
and then there's like a lot of food
around here and then like ebt
and stuff like that so trying
to get my life together but
so are drugs a part of your life huh
are drugs a part of your life um
like i said marijuana occasionally
i need to get a wreck but yeah
i'm drinking occasionally so
yeah but no no crack or crystal meth
that i know of why unless someone lay
something
and a lot of the women down here will
support themselves by
dating guys for money they're having
trouble with that
and people coming in here
have you ever have you ever done that
for money
um i'm sure you get asked all the time
uh i'm sorry what'd you say
a lot of the a lot of the women down
here in skid row will make money by
dating guys
for money okay you know what i mean
have you ever done anything like that
no oh no no no
no
so where do you where do you stay now um
i'm embarrassed um are you staying in a
tent
um yeah like i said it was a friend and
then um
shelter or something um i'm sorry i just
like lost what i was gonna say
um yeah like i said right now at the
front and then um i'm looking
into getting into a shelter the women's
center at fifth in san pedro can
probably help you
yeah yeah so
i think if you showed up if you showed
up in the state you're in right now
you'd probably get taken care of nicely
i think
i can take you over there when we're
done oh the
the women's center uh-huh okay
i know where it sounds like seven yeah
it's just a few blocks away
yeah do you have any contact with your
family your mom
um yeah a little bit yeah
has she seen you lately um
so you don't you don't think you might
be pregnant um
no but i do need to get um checked out
so
yeah you look like you're probably about
eight eight or eight you look at you're
about eight or nine months pregnant
yeah i know huh it's not good um
detox yeah i need to go to doctor
do you have any children of your own um
two
and where are they you say what are you
raising them
um
um no one is in um foster care and one
is with his
father we need to
get that situated
why did you lose the child to the foster
system huh
how did you lose a child your child to
the foster system um
like a year or two ago how did that
why did you have your child taken away
um
just um from not having like a permanent
place to stay because i was with my mom
and i guess
my mom has too much going on so i don't
really
you know it's not really stable
so yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned by living here on the street
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
um
i don't know nothing well i'll just say
do you have any friends um
yeah a couple not really about myself
have you had bad things happen to you on
the street
um no not really
none of the guys are giving you a hard
time nothing like that of course
but mostly just stressed that's it
you're stressed
what are you stressed about um
i don't know just everything it's just
in general that's a stressful life for
sure
monique thank you for sharing your story
and i
hope you see a doctor about your
whatever's going on in your stomach
[Music]
i wish you the best of luck i'm going to
give you some money for food maybe a
place to stay and
can i take you to the women's center can
i take you to the women's center
that's i mean the the the one right
there with the
big giant building yeah or the shelter
yeah
um isn't it closed no i think they're
they have
they can get housing for you
um
fine i'm fine yeah
[ __ ] i'll only take care of this
supposed to have you because well thank
you for talking with me
yeah okay okay you're welcome
all right okay thank you darling